[موسيقى]
في ذروه الحركه التجاريه وحركه الطلاب
دخلت قوه خاصه من الجيش الاسرائيلي حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه من نابلس
وحاصرت منزلا تحصن فيه عدد من المسلحين
الفلسطينيين
اشتباكات عنيفه ووابل من الرصاص
والمتفجرات القاها الجيش الاسرائيلي
باتجاه المنزل ما اوقع ثلاثه قتلى قالت
اسرائيل انهم متورطون في عمليه اطلاق
النار في الاغوار
من الجنود والمدرعات حوالين البلده
القديمه
والصواريخ كانت بشكل مش طبيعي يعني ما
همهم اذا كان مين جوا بالبيت ما همهم اذا
هالاطفال رايحين على المدارس وصلنا
فيتامين لثلاثه شهداء كان هناك تشويه
فيتامين في جثتين كانت هناك بدون راس
والجثه الثالثه كانت اصابات عده الرصاصات
في الراس وصلت ثلاث اصابات مع ناريه في
وضع متوسط الى بسيطه في الاطراف السفليه
اطلاق نار كثيف رافق خروج الجنازات من
مستشفى رفيديا الحكومي وسط اجراءات عسكريه
وحصار مشدد على محيط مدينه نابلس تخوفا من
رد الفصائل على العمليات الاسرائيليه
اكثر من 200 جندي وضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي شاركوا في العمليه التي تقول
اسرائيل انها قتلت خلالها منفذي عمليه
اطلاق نار في الاغوار ادت الى مقتل ثلاث
مستوطنات بدايه الشهر الماضي من حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه بنابلس خالد
القاسم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات